it's almost Halloween
so what's your
pleasure
suspense or
[Music]
Gore yeah it's uh the episode that
coming out closest to Halloween so we
got to get all thematic with it well we
don't have to but I like to and I don't
have anything particular in mind at
least as far as specifics goes so I
thought this time it'd be nice to talk
more broad Strokes because if we're
talking horror if we're talking
scary I feel like a lot of entertainment
can be lumped into leaning primarily
into one of two things
suspense and
Gore now uh one can make the argument
that those are not mutually exclusive
you can have both and I would say yes
that's true but I feel like most films
that sort of fall into the horror
setting uh or genre for the most part
tend to lean one way or the other and in
some cases very very very heavily there
are some incredibly suspenseful tens
movies that have not a lot of Gore some
even at PG-13 I'll cite you at least one
later and there are plenty of Gore
filled films television now thanks to
the uh fewer restrictions on things like
streaming that are not
suspenseful and they're not
tense they're not even necessarily
trying to be whether intended or not
these two aspects are often at odds with
each other at least they are for me as a
viewer and I find it interesting to talk
about why that is and why I tend to
favor
suspense over
Gore at least I am if you're going to
make me choose let's talk broad Strokes
here what is suspense suspense is that
tension the classic way to describe that
was done by Alfred Hitchcock horrible
man great director there have been a lot
of them if you weren't aware but he said
that if you have a
scene set at a restaurant and a bomb
goes off and it just blows up the
restaurants you can startle the audience
for basically a second at the moment of
detonation however if you show the
audience the bomb under the table at the
beginning of the scene then you will
have 10 minutes worth of tension as they
know that bomb is going to go off now
that's a very simplified way of putting
it but basically startling is easy
anybody can startle building tension
building
suspense making people afraid of what
comes next partly because they aren't
entirely sure what it's going to be of
not knowing when it's going to happen
even if they have a sense of what it
will
be that takes some craft that's not to
say that Gore doesn't when I say Gore I
mean
over-the-top gooey drippy bloody
depictions of physical violence there is
a craft to Gore as well although I would
say more often than not the crafting
Gore is on the part of the special
effects team and not necessarily the
directors the writers uh the
cinematographers they can do things to
enhance or best present that but I
honestly feel like when I see something
with good Gore at least is um praised as
having good Gore I'm I'm praising the uh
efforts of the effects team more than
anybody else whereas something that is
suspenseful that is
tense well that's across the board
that's the script that's the actors
that's the director the cinematographer
the music if they do it right that all
builds the tension whereas the gore
is well it's kind of just however long
as on the screen now granted part of my
feeling about that being a dichotomy
probably has a little bit to do with my
age because let's be honest Gore as a uh
real sort of thing unto itself in horror
the idea that horror is or should be um
some kind of delivery vehicle for gory
kills
that's that sense is kind of very
informed by my growing up in the80s and
'90s
lots of 80s Classics some I like many of
which bore me that gor hounds really
love all kinds of zombie movies all
kinds of you know the Return of the
Living Dead and all these you know
gritty nasty oh practical head
decapitation oo like it started in the
70s the 80s is where it kind of took off
like you don't watch Friday the 13th
because you want to feel tense you do it
to see the bloody kills and I'm not
knocking that as an experience there can
be catharsis and enjoyment in that but
again for me at least it's rarely scary
and it often seemed especially in the
80s and into the 90s that if something
was going for Gore that it basically
just didn't bother being suspenseful
like no look we're here for the gore we
know that's what you're here for like so
just let us do this is what it could
often feel like and not even necessarily
in a they're not putting any effort into
any other parts of the thing uh sort of
way there were films that were gory that
just you know weren't trying to be scary
and while you would get a handful of
gory and suspenseful films I think John
Carpenter's The Thing probably stands at
least from the 8S as a really good
example of something that did both with
very visceral body horror imagery but
also being very tense for its paranoid
setting that is an Exemplar and a
luminary of the era for a reason it's an
exception most Gore just wasn't too
concerned with being suspenseful or even
scary it was there to be fun and I'm not
above finding Gore fun but that's
actually part of why I think I enjoy
Gore more in action movies than I do in
horror movies cuz as I said Gore can be
cathartic and actually as a punctuation
to an action scene like a really
knockdown drag out fight between a hero
I'm rooting for and a villain I hate to
punctuate that with Gore at the end like
yeah that can enhance the moment in a
way that makes you pump your fist in the
air so again I'm not knocking Gore on
its
own but sort of moving on past the 80s
and 90s that's when we got saw and we
hit hostile and we got the
torture porn era and I feel like in many
ways that was an attempt to strip the
silliness and the fun out of Gore
because while it wasn't really to my
taste most gory movies from the 80s the
90s they were fun they were designed to
be fun by and large once you started
getting into these
things I like these things aren't to my
taste so I'm not being like nobody would
would like this but they're not trying
to be fun they're trying to be visceral
they're trying to be
unsettling but the sense of fun that
used to be there was kind of gone and
while that Dynamic has shifted in terms
of the way Gore heavy horror films are
being utilized in more recent time
versus my more formative years it still
doesn't really appeal to
me but
tension sus
Spence what's around the corner what's
coming
next when it's done right and it isn't
always but when it
is that can sit with me
forever the scariest movie that I've
ever seen and I stand by this it is
still my number one scary movie I've
ever seen and maybe someday if there's
interest I'll do a full Deep dive into
this thing thing it's the 1978 version
of Invasion of the Body Snatchers
because the sense of
paranoia the sense of
unease among the characters the sense
that they don't know who they can trust
you don't know if you can believe what
you're
seeing that permeates the entire film
it's not Gore free there's one gorish
moment um towards the tail end but
that's never what's stuck with me the
scenes where characters are talking and
they cannot figure out how to even get
out of the city because there's no one
they can reach out in contact and
they're not even entirely sure who can
be trusted if anybody for all they know
they are the only people left in the
city who have not been replaced by
duplicates that tension is basically the
entire
film and that thing has stuck with me
way more than any
bloodier gory kill that I've ever seen
in anything and the degree to which a
gory moment would have to take it to
stick with me the way something like
that movie stuck with me it's going to
be a level of Gore that I honestly I
just don't want to watch again that is a
personal taste thing but you
know I'm allowed to set my limits I told
you that I'd mention a
PG-13 rated incredibly tense for me very
scary movie The Ring the American remake
of the Ring directed by Gore verbinski I
think is still a masterly suspenseful
film one of the nice things about
suspense is because it does not require
that visceral level that Gore goes into
suspense can be Supernatural it can be
alien it can be just somebody stalking
another human
being but I do find that when you have a
true sense of I don't know what's going
on that can really ramp it up and the
ring does that really
well and are there some moments of like
unsettling imagery in terms of like the
way some of the bodies are twisted and
shaped like yeah but again it got away
with the
PG-13
so I think that says a lot another one
the woman in black starring Daniel
Radcliff also PG13 also incredibly tense
tension from Darkness from creaking
floors from slow pans from a chair
rocking out of nowhere small tiny things
just presented at a pace and in a way
that doesn't feel like it's killing time
until the gore is here this is why
you're here this is the point and I
think that's another thing for me when
Gore is more of the uh intended point of
a thing it can often for me feel like
the time in between the Gory moments is
filler now ideally it's still
entertaining filler but it can really
feel like yeah okay uh when do we when
do we get to the next kill let's let's
pick up the pace here to me someone
working their way down a dark
hallway can get to me far more than any
quantity of blood or amount of
prosthetic
viscera and not necessarily because I'm
expecting a jump scare the best
suspenseful movies can make me feel
tense even when I still know what's
coming I can watch jaws and still feel
that tension as it builds as the music
kicks in and I'm not going to bring up
the rating on that one technically it's
PG but like it existed before the PG-13
rating as it it is it would maybe be R
now I don't know up in the air but like
I'm not going to bring up the rating
there cuz PG was a whole different thing
back
then
but I can watch a movie like that I can
watch The Woman in Black I can watch
Invasion of the Body
Snatchers and still get
tense even though it can't jump scare me
if there are jump scares in in those
movies I had them memorized a long time
ago but I still get tense I still feel
myself tighten up a little bit when
everything's hitting
right
but it's it's kind of wrong of me to
imply that tension suspense and Gore are
incompatible I mean there are things
like the thing which I mentioned
although ultimately I do feel that one
leans more on Gore than uh than on
tension the tension is there certainly
in some scenes but taken as a whole it's
more of a Gore feature than a tension
feature it's just got more tension than
I think it's standard for a lot of Gore
Focus
movies but there is one
movie that I think gets the balance 100%
perfectly and it has one famously gory
scene but that's kind of it but it is
legitimate gory and the tension as it
built to it and the tension that comes
after it because so often times Gore Rel
relieves the tension like all all this
tense moments like what's gonna happen
Gore oh okay there's the thing that
happened kind of like how as a as a
comedian or a comedic movie is building
up the tension before the punchline of
something and then the relief is the
laugh with Gore the relief is the
oh okay now that tension's gone that
tension's
relieved but I can definitely think of a
movie where when the gore
happened tension wasn't
gone the tension ratcheted
up and it kept it the whole way through
and that moment of Gore was not the end
it wasn't the climax my friends the
original alien directed by Ridley Scott
with an astounding
cast tense from the moment the crew of
the Nostromo sat down on that
planet much less when they went into
this ship saw this being didn't know
what any of it was and unfortunately I
can't project myself back to a time of
not knowing what the xenomorph is I've
always known even before I saw the movie
I I just by cultural osmosis and
freaking Space Balls I knew what it was
but I can still get a sense just because
of how well that tension is still
preserved that tension up until the face
hugger ends up on a member of the
crew and then the
relaxation in the Cantina until he
starts to cough the thing's not on his
face anymore he should be fine I don't
know what's going
on that chest bursting scene is not just
iconic because it's
unexpected and it's not just iconic
because it's
gory it's iconic because it ratchets up
everything there was a tiny Lev of
attention when the face hugger wasn't on
him anymore but now everything just went
to hell and it does it in a moment of
very visceral
Gore that just projects the film into
its second half and it is on Rocket Fuel
from there out it holds the tension of
this thing is now on the ship it holds
that tension to the point that it
doesn't have to show you any of the
other kills in any
detail and it doesn't it doesn't need
to Darkness sound
implication you don't need the gore
every time because you had the taste of
what this thing just as this little this
little tiny thing bursting out of
somebody you got a sense of what it can
do and now it's
bigger one could argue that the
destruction of Ash the Android is also a
moment of Gore and I would say a little
bit not quite on the same level so call
it a secondary sort of topup a little
bit more but there's no actual blood and
it is an unsettling image to be
sure the the way he looks when they when
they smash him up but it's not the same
but taken as a whole altogether that
movie is a perfect melding of suspense
and
Gore in a way that I can't think of any
other film that's done it
and it's why ultimately if you're going
to make me pick one I'm going to pick
suspense but if you want to point me to
something else that balanced both as
well as the original alien did I want to
hear about
it give me some recommendations down in
the comments let's talk about it what
are your thoughts on my Notions of sort
of dividing these two ways of
approaching things in general I mean as
I said this is a perspective partially
informed by just my age 40s woo middle
age
that's that's a terrifying thought it's
reality though but whatever your
thoughts are on any of this down in the
comments let's talk about it patreon
pays the bills enables me to do this as
my
living but don't worry too much about
that like share subscribe it all helps
me out what I really want you to
remember
though is that you are
beautiful you are valid you are loved
you are the council I am just running
the meetings and until next time this
council is
adjourned be safe this
Halloween and have
[Music]
fun time to thank some patreon backers
and in the spirit of October I'd like to
thank Robin Moore Zubin L Fuller goddess
aligha to rock the thing that goes dink
in the anime r Ruth Oliver B solitary
pictures or bton Melinda Walters Jen
Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks FX the brle
Robin Powell Tracy scrapit angry caspel
Dave Hall and rosn
Bennett thank you for your assistance um
I don't know I might try theming the
shout outs in the future I don't know
we'll see thank
you
[Music]
w